[Música]
y en los temas de salud nos acompañan a
nuestra periodista especializada en el
tema mar Romero sala Mar buenos días
Feliz miércoles para usted Buenos días
María Clara estamos ya mitad de semana
Estamos a mitad de semana y aprovechamos
para hablar del Día Mundial sin tabaco
un hábito que está dejando alrededor de
8 millones de personas que mueren a
causa de esto Así es María Clara Esas
son las cifras Al menos que proporciona
a la Organización Mundial de la Salud y
aprovechemos aquí para recordar que la
parte Adictiva de un cigarrillo es la
nicotina pero que El cigarrillo contiene
muchas otras cosas especialmente a raíz
de la combustión a partir de encender el
cigarrillo ahí se liberan muchos otros
tóxicos por ejemplo el plomo o el
Arsénico que es directamente un veneno
también aspiramos cuando fumamos
monóxido de carbono que es el mismo humo
que sale de los tubos de escape de los
coches y las consecuencias sobre la
salud las conocemos
estamos hablando de enfermedades
cardiovasculares estamos hablando de
varios tipos de cáncer también
enfermedades pulmonares entre muchas
otras pero vamos a repasar las cifras
que estabas dando a nivel global las
Vamos a repasar a nivel de América
Latina porque el lunes se publicó un
estudio liderado por el instituto de
efectividad clínica y sanitaria de
Buenos Aires que estudió el consumo de
tabaco en ocho países de América Latina
que engloban el 80% de la población de
la región y vemos que deja
351.000 muertes anuales 2,2 millones de
casos de enfermedad de las cuales el 6%
aproximadamente son casos de cáncer y el
40% aproximadamente son enfermedades
cardiovasculares Y que además esto
provoca un costo de 5.000 millones de
dólares nos referimos a los cuidados de
la salud y las pérdidas económicas que
tienen estas enfermedades uno de cada 10
dólares además en este sentido de los
presupuestos de salud van a atender
estas enfermedades provocadas por el
cigarrillo 5 mil millones de dólares
anuales en pérdidas no sino 50.000
Perdón
yo le propongo que hablemos de un
impacto del que poco se habla Porque
estos de la salud digamos que los
venimos conociendo desde hace mucho
tiempo pero también afecta el medio
ambiente específicamente con los
cultivos que recordemos que el tabaco
proviene de una planta si este tema
espero que te interese especialmente
también como cronista de medio ambiente
y además es el tema en el que se enfoca
la OMS este año no la campaña contra el
tabaco este año de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud va en este sentido
en el mundo hay unos 4 millones de
hectáreas dedicadas a las plantaciones
de tabaco y aquí hemos destacado los
países de cada región que más a
plantaciones de tabaco tienen en América
Latina es Brasil Turquía Pakistán
también importante destacar África el
país que más cultivos tiene zimbabue
Pero hay muchos que le siguen muy de
cerca y de hecho es una de las regiones
que más cultivos de tabaco tiene pero
por supuesto el que gana a todos es
india con más de un millón de hectáreas
Perdón china con más de un millón de
hectáreas Solo que cultiva este país y
lo que a lo que llama la OMS
Precisamente es que estos países están
en regiones o son países que sufren de
inseguridad alimentaria de problemas de
hambre que deberían dedicarse estas
zonas de plantación a cultivos al que
puedan alimentar a sus poblaciones no
Además es importante destacar que las
plantaciones de tabaco contribuyen en un
5% a la deforestación mundial es decir
que también afectan al medio ambiente y
que son lugares donde los Derechos
Humanos especialmente en algunos países
quedan en un segundo plano muchas de
estas plantaciones emplean trabajo
infantil muchos niños pierden escuela
por ayudar a sus familias en estas
plantaciones de tabaco y además se
exponen a problemas de salud graves los
trabajadores en estas plantaciones
pueden absorber nicotina a través de la
piel por el manejo de las hojas del
tabaco y nivel de nicotina equivalente a
50 cigarrillos al día Todo esto además
sin mencionar que son empresas que
suelen recibir muchos subsidios
agrícolas de los gobiernos sin duda unos
impactos del trabajo de los que poco se
suele hablar y yo le agrego solo un dato
rápidamente y es Pakistán como uno de
los países donde más se siembra tabaco y
además Pakistán uno de los países más
vulnerables a la crisis climática
pasemos ahora a otra Arista del tabaco y
son los vapeadores Porque estos se han
planteado como una alternativa al tabaco
funcionan no funcionan bueno Esto lo
vamos a ver probablemente con más
detalle con nuestro invitado del día que
viene después de esta sección podemos
decir que es cierto que sortea o evita
algunos de los riesgos del tabaco
precisamente que vienen a partir de la
combustión de encender de poner fuego a
la hoja de tabacos es algo que se evita
con El cigarrillo electrónico pero
existen muchas dudas respecto realmente
así son más beneficiosos o se pueden
funcionar para dejar para hacer que las
personas dejen de fumar tabaco en
cigarrillo y vamos a aprovechar esta
sección para hacer una advertencia
precisamente a los estudios que hablan
de estos temas alrededor de los
cigarrillos electrónicas electrónicos
sabemos que en su día las empresas
tabacaleras se esforzaron muchísimo en
intentar ocultar o en intentar
distorsionar datos científicos de
alrededor de los efectos nocivos del
cigarrillo y el mercado del vapeo es
también un mercado poderoso es un
mercado que puede dar muchos beneficios
y en ese sentido lo que hizo un grupo de
investigadores fue revisar todos estos
estudios que se publican alrededor del
vapeo lo publicaron en la revista tobaco
indus de sises y vieron que más de un
tercio de estos estudios no dicen nada
alrededor de sí tienen conflictos de
interés o no eso es una información
básica para saber si un estudio es
fiable o no de los que sí declaraban
conflictos de interés un 13% lo
declaraba con empresas farmacéuticas
algunas de las cuales Por cierto
inducen a que el vapeo Se use como una
alternativa más saludable al tabaco y un
10% eran empresas con conflictos de
intereses con empresas precisamente de
vapeo entonces hacemos un llamado a
siempre intentar revisar las fuentes de
donde veamos las informaciones porque es
muy fácil influir al final en este tipo
de informaciones científica